- We're having Native American food.
- Which is really, we're just eating
American food, for the first time.
(upbeat funky music)
It smells amazing in here!
- Ohh.
- I am so excited to see how people react
to this. (laughs)
They're probably going to die.
(dramatic upbeat music)
- I ate a light lunch today actually
to prepare for this.
And that's why.
- We have to share?
(both make airplane sounds)
- Oh my God, it smells so nutty.
- This taste healthy as (beep).
- I feel like this is what you eat
when you have your life together.
- So many grains.
- [Guy] Grains.
A lot of grains.
- My poop is gonna just be perfect.
- This is definitely like
a unique kind of rice.
I don't think I've ever
had anything like this.
- What point in history do you think
we started pooping so poorly?
- Hmm, whenever white people
got involved. (laughter)
- Wild rice, is not actually rice.
It's a grass seed.
- It's not really rice.
- We just ate grass?
- Oh.
- Well, we learn something everyday.
(upbeat music)
- We got ourselves some.
- [Guy] Oh, this smells good!
- This is like soup my grandma would make.
- There's corn.
There's beans.
There's a bunch of different vegetables.
- The three sisters are
beans, corn, and squash
and they were all grown together,
almost like one big crop.
- Fourth sister, she
can go (beep) herself.
- The cornstalk would grow.
The bean sprout would
grow up the cornstalk.
The squash would cover the ground
and protect the root system.
- Oh...
- [Guy] They're called the
three sisters because they lived together.
- Oh, that's so sweet.
- [Guy] Wow.
- I want to hang out with those sisters
because this (beep) is good!
- Definitely see the similarities between
Native American food
and African American food.
- This definitely tastes
like something that
latin folk would make.
- It actually tastes like
tortilla soup a little bit too.
- It feels familiar to me.
It feels like home.
(upbeat fast-paced music)
- I've been waiting all day for this.
- Oohhh.
- [Guy] Wow!
- It's cute!
- Aww man, this is just
a frisbee of goodness,
right here.
- I should, I'm just gonna pick it up.
- Mmm, (beep)!
- This is so good.
- An Indian taco is fry bread with chili
and all this dank ass stuff. (laughs)
- This one is not healthy.
- This is diabetes on a plate.
- Dang, this is some good
ass drunk food right here.
- Oh my God!
- This bread taste different
than any kind of other
bread I've ever had.
- And it kicks a funnel cake's ass.
- I feel like a lot of
Native culture hasn't crossed
over into main true American culture
and that's a damn shame
because this food is so damn good.
- There's certain cultures
in which we don't have
access to.
I mean, I don't know
why we don't have a ton
of access to Native American culture.
- I feel like people think that like
all Native traditions and everything
is like dead and this is some ancient food
that we are reincarnating, right now.
It's still something that
people eat every single day.
- And if this is hiding
within Native culture,
then I can't imagine what
else is waiting for us.
- It's a shame because obviously
Native American culture
has so much to offer.
And food is just one of them.
- I'm honored to be eating this.
This deliciousness.
- It's so good.
What, what do you want from me?